so chapter 3 23 is called Anglican
Renaissance what were the Anglican is
they were the Church of England here are
the United States after the Revolution
they're called the episcopal church
apart because they want to divorce
themselves from being seen as tied with
you know to to the king of england and
all the other things alone with that and
for a long time being English was not
consider to be a particularly good thing
you know after the Revolution but then
times change and you notice that here in
America English always has a certain
prestige you know if you speak with an
English accent that kind of raises your
class status and Anglican Church was
actually affected by them or the
Episcopal Church was affected by that
here in the United States like your book
tells you in the Northeast particularly
New York at Boston and Chicago these
areas were were developing very quickly
a lot of money coming in a lot of new
wealth being generated and a lot of the
wealthy people found themselves leaving
their their other churches and becoming
Episcopalians now why would the party
people trade up so to speak with
churches well what sense with that and I
do you think again in any of you ever
seen somebody doing that they like shop
around for churches until they find one
that matches their their perceived
status or the stats they'd like to have
there's a lot of famous people that
actually are ain't our Episcopalians
that you never would gasps Worth and
some of them converted later on so why
do people do that yeah
that's very good so if your wealth is
increasing if your income is increasing
generally people want to be around
people like them right so the Anglicans
or the Episcopalians were some of the
wealthiest the most well-connected
members of the Protestant establishment
their main rivals were the Presbyterians
particularly in the south so your book
points out a lot of people were being
attracted to this denomination that
represented the allure of English
customs and traditions your book talks
about prep schools this entire network
of prep schools that develop based on
English models so it's not just about
English you know the Church of England
it's about English culture about you
know sort of raising your status you
know for example a lot of celebrities
get made fun of because they start out
American and then they start speaking
with an English accent you think of
anybody recently that they like the last
person I remember getting flak for that
was Madonna but even people more
recently than that why do they do that
well because there's sort of an
inferiority complex that goes on and
being English seems to be a bit more
cultured so that was the case at that
time the book also talks about the
revival of male and female Anglican
orders remember Henry the Eighth and
closed the monasteries sent all the bugs
home this was something pretty pretty
revolutionary to start new humanistic
orders or restart them in the new book
talks about the institutional Church
we've already talked about that in terms
of the social gospel the institutional
church is the church that is providing a
lot of social services and many of us
just take this for granted as being part
with the church we do and having a soup
kitchen for example but that was a
fairly new thing and the Anglican got
involved with that as well so it talks
about the other connection here to the
to the social gospel and liver
Protestantism and before this this time
you maybe talk in terms of is a mystical
Church low Church or high Church what
this meant was did they have a more
evangelical type of style flow church
was more like other American churches or
were they more like Roman Catholics and
having a big emphasis on liturgy
Anglican churches that are high church
are often called smells and bells
because you know insects which has a
nice smell to its frankincense or things
like that and then bells you know
ringing at the appropriate times so this
is a big issue here and then they added
to that something that you recall wrong
lesson broadchurch and the broadchurch
had to do with social engagement going
to do it changing society so it talks
about this guy Philip Brooks in the
broad church movement and the idea was
to try to transcend this split and say
everybody can fit it everybody can do
one now in practice that didn't always
turn out like that that's that's where
they were doing so a lot of the things
that affected other Protestant
denominations you know the questions
about biblical criticism evolution
really didn't affect Anglicans that much
compared to the other Protestant
denominations perfect if you have a
broad churchy and say well we all just
sort of agree to disagree but we're all
part of the same big umbrella now your
book talks about the Anglican
Renaissance when you hear that term
Renaissance what do you think what's up
very good that's literal meaning nice
offices is birth rebirth of what though
what would it mean this contact
explosion and culture yeah you're
talking about the Italian and Northern
European Renaissance right not the
Anglican Renaissance here there wasn't
an explosion of taking up totally new
stuff yeah you're right at that time
they you know we covered a lot of
ancient greek stuff and they took that
as a model and they generated a lot of
new other stuff so rebirth of the arts
and you can talk about renaissance in
terms of other things you can talk about
an economic Renaissance you can talk
about an educational Renaissance here
we're talking about things that are
specific to the Anglicans and so if they
are in a with surgically oriented a
church oriented denomination one of the
things that's going to be very important
for them has to do with worship this is
the structure of worship now your book
talks an awful lot about architecture
why do you why do you think architecture
is important think about it like this
room for example are there any ways that
this room could be reworked so it would
be a better educational experience for
you yeah you could too plus is the walls
and the ceilings make the sound better
that's very true what else those are
utilitarian thing what do you guys like
you know you're you're in a lot of
classrooms which which classrooms you
like here yeah yeah
could be kind of cool like if we didn't
have to pull this this thing down and
totally block all of the the boards if
we could use both at the same time okay
that's that's a good idea anything about
like the physical appearance of things
here those would be nice there are some
back there but you can't see anything
through them and they're just a little
narrow slits why are windows important
yea rather than this this fluorescent
light what else about one does what do
you feel what does it feel like yeah
they let you daydream okay yeah that's
very true I did a lot of that as a
student maybe some of you it you can't
like to do that and that's now they'll
think about carrying out worship where
it's the same thing the same sort of
pattern week after week after week after
week what are you doing with your
daydream what what part of you is
engaged very good and religious service
is in part about engaging the
imagination so is education by the way
you know an education works well you
come away from something and you've
thought of some new things and it
doesn't necessarily have to be whatever
the lecture was talking about you know
if you're in a really nice location you
might think of things that you know get
sparked by like some tangential point of
lecture that turn out to be very
important for you and when it comes to
worship the same thing goes for why they
design the cathedrals how many of you
ever like been in a Cathedral either
here in the States or you traveled
abroad what did you notice about these
things yeah good they had different
colored windows that you could see lots
of different light girl and it was just
really pretty okay so actual view is
something that's emphasized what does
the stained glass supposed to do these
eyes look pretty yeah they usually tell
like a story
yeah you know these two called the
cathedrals Bibles in stone because you
could like look around imagine if you
were illiterate I'm not saying includes
were illiterate they were actually some
of the most literate people in this this
time that we're talking about but at the
ancient cathedrals you could look around
and you can see all these stories
depicted so if you wanted to teach your
kids about you know Samson and Delilah
look over there you've got an image that
you can actually tie that with so the
Anglican Tsar doing stuff like that and
they're they're reincorporate enough
that was something that was seen as you
know going against the low Church saying
some of you looked at those images of
Puritan meeting houses you notice
there's nothing some white walls white
walls and woodwork and the woodwork is
not ornate there's no special moldings
or anything like that it's purely to
latarian the idea with those with that
the the cathedrals the churches
themselves could represent what was
supposed to be happening in the service
so your book gives a few examples of the
you know the Gothic Revival and there's
a few churches that are worth pointing
out that's really most of what they talk
about in this chapter so let's look at a
few of these and talk about Trinity
Church which is where does Evelyn there
we go Boston is Trinity Church Trinity
served to display not only this guy
Brooks is preaching but other arts that
were undergoing a revival at the time so
sculpture you would play sculptures
around Commission people who are famous
mirrors clergy of other denominations
were also being drawn into this where
the Anglicans would go they would tend
to bring a lot of the other churches
with them at least the ones that were
attracted to that sort of thing your
book also talks about the National
Cathedral how many of you before you
read this near that we actually have a
cathedral for the United States of
America nobody the guy that got used for
you know the 911 memorials
service whenever we have some major
event they use this Cathedral it's
actually an Episcopalian Cathedral so
you might say well how can they do that
well you know there's sort of an
understanding that it's going to be used
for interfaith interdenominational
services but in its day job it's a
cathedral that's used by the Episcopal
Church USA it was deliberately designed
that way so this had a major impact not
only on Anglicans but outside of them
Presbyterians on Lutheran's all these
other denominations got drawn in the
more high Church they were the less
loads less evangelical they were the
more they they started to say well we
need to have beautiful churches as well
we need to spend some time on the
architecture we need to commit a
commission famous artists for this sort
of thing your book also talks about some
some literary figures some of whom
you've probably heard of some perhaps
not how many of you read it when you
were kids Madeleine L'Engle like swiftly
tilting planet or wrinkle in time what
else does she write you remember you
read the series chichi was a piss
capelean author and those books have a
kind of you know Christian slant to them
without actually talking about Christ
very much or without talking about God
very much there's there's kind of a
theology built into them you guys all
know about CS Lewis but it would see
famous for yeah Narnia's the land talked
about in seven books yeah the lion the
witch and wardrobe before the Cardinals
about yet yeah yeah so he makes up this
entire universe part of you know part of
the story takes place in this world part
of the takes place in Narnia and what's
he doing in there he's actually telling
a lot of stories that are pretty overtly
christian in
structure like you know those who are
you the sort of thing what does the
athlon represent that you already
answered that for right now God the
athlon represents God and how do you
know that because he's a lion that's not
really what's the key thing that he does
in that first book yeah well it doesn't
meet like the stone breaks and it's like
Easter right first he's sacrificed for
the wrong kid Edmond as Edmund was a
traitor and then he takes his place
who's that like Judas is the traitor
yeah who's taking them to place like
Jesus right so there's a lot of
Christian imagery built into that that's
part of this Gillikin Renaissance Louis
actually was a university professor he
were a lot of really interesting books
besides the nardy and stuff but this
isn't it so this is an important chapter
it's a very short one but it's sort of
telling you how things got steered in a
certain direction